[Music]
and hero hubby news oh I want one of
those oh you do have one right there
this Katie
East LA life submitted by whoa I saved
myself from the e Sally life oh really
okay submitted by Dale from Canada
Canada a man is lucky to be alive after
he was stabbed while trying to protect
his wife from kidnappers how important
is she
squishy his wife stupid no like they
would want to kidnap her like who is she
stupid I like calling you stupid and
you're stupid of course you wouldn't do
that for me real stupid oh let me tell
you something so much trying to kidnap
you you're running away really strong so
I don't think that what they see you
that's the first thing they're gonna try
to do if anything they're gonna look at
you'd be like we gotta go for somebody a
little easier kidnappers gonna come with
the ski mask and you're gonna see the
eyes go life insurance immediately do
you want some life you show because I'm
sorry yeah so this take this took place
in Houston and so the husband here he
had just arrived at a water burger at
1:00 a.m. what a burger if you get the
fries fresh it's pretty good mmm yeah
and then so he arrived with his wife and
as soon as they got out these two men
they approached the couple and demanded
for the man to give him than his wallet
and his phone and so he did and then
that's when they started demanding that
the wife get in the car oh they had just
recently found out that she was pregnant
too oh [ __ ]
and so um so that's when the husband was
like hell no you're not getting the car
and he started putting up a fight and
then that's when one of the dudes grad
like pulled out a knife and started
slashing him and he like cut like he
slashed his throat and oh yeah and then
Joey yeah so then like he was just like
left in the puddle of his blood oh my
wife luckily the guys like they ran away
after like all that happened and then so
eyes are scary yeah so then the wife
instead of waiting for the cops to come
like she somehow managed to put
into their car and then she drove him to
the hospital and luckily he's okay but
crazy it's a crazy attack there was no
one else at the water Berger like what
about the people are doing a drive-thru
and stuff robbed somebody has such a
happy happy business man nice dad let
him sleep how he likes the way she was
protected yeah I thought she was like
getting kidnapped because she was
important like VIP there you know like a
she was a princess or something like I
thought it their way like my own idea of
like what happened here and I think like
these dudes are probably like obviously
they're in some like underground [ __ ]
like they're probably into like human
trafficking and they probably wanted to
get hurt like then we're gonna rape her
probably or saw her [ __ ] oh wow that's
dangerous yeah see how do you deal with
something like that if something happens
like that's why I like to carry a gun
because you hear stories like this and
then people go you don't need guns well
what if you you and your wife are
hanging out and someone has a knife and
you don't have anything and you're a
small person and they're willing on
there's like two guys that are six feet
tall you know like what you gonna do and
they're gonna take your [ __ ] wife and
in like user as a sex slave she's gonna
be like in a different country and you
can't even find her that's some [ __ ] my
mom thinks about every time I travel
really gonna happen but it's funny cuz
you go to the safest places like Japan
and like Frank she still thinks that's
gonna happen [ __ ] you're gonna go to
Hawaii me huh and they're not Hawaii the
Hawaii locals are gonna come pick you
she thinks like that though like she
loves me and she's so paranoid that
she's like she gave me the takin video
she's like watch this you can get
educate but you know what's crazy though
she's not wrong you're [ __ ] lying
right now no she's not wrong though cuz
this is Houston of all places Houston is
a major city in hell I mean don't tell
her that dude it made you see it's a
major city in America just don't expect
[ __ ] to happen in
happens yeah I don't Whataburger - yeah
it's like a big French imagine you're
just having your cheeseburger and then
you're happy your wife is pregnant and
you're like ooh and then you walk
outside these guys like give me your
wife's [ __ ] give them my wife's [ __ ]
hey no kidding I would not do you know
what's interesting though when I see
people with guns and concealed weapons
and when they protect themselves
properly it's never like in the movies
you don't I mean who's in the movies
they're like pop pop top like this and
the guy said whoa what the [ __ ] where he
just bowed precision kills but what
happened is this everywhere
it's [ __ ] frightening a [ __ ] but they
don't know what they're doing yeah - ooh
yeah it's like some scary [ __ ] though
most people don't practice yeah it's
it's scary
not that one security guard though at
the bank he just went boom got him I was
like oh [ __ ] but he was the ex-cop
though he was captain - yeah he's
retired so he's he's super it was crazy
cuz after he shot him the guy just fell
in he died right there but it was like
he just looked at him when ha you know
that shooting class I took over the
weekend like a couple months ago the
instructor he's special forces in the
army so he's been in it for like 15
years
and he was just saying like in the
movies where they're always like holding
a person hostage and know it's like
don't come any closer I'm gonna shoot
him like there's so trained that they
don't even have to hesitate they just
pop the gun issue because they'll know
they'll never hit the hostage hey that's
just crazy huh for them it's like like
all those guys have 300 400 confirmed
kills and it's just oh [ __ ] immediately
like for them they're doing surgery so
when they're shooting that they say like
when they're doing target practice you
want to get your groups as tight as
possible but he's so used to shooting
he's literally doing surgery girl's
heart pancreas stomach spine like he
needs that accurate yeah he's placing
he's placing and then they also get
coached so even though they're in a
combat gun fighting environment they get
coached by like Olympic shooters like
people with like those
coach they're being coached real-time as
they're in war oh no like you know how
like let's say I'm a competitive power
lifter yeah then I might get a specific
like quads or at the squat coach or a
bench coach so I get specialty training
so for them they're a combat gunfighter
but in the offseason there's still
honing that specific skill so don't get
like a knife knife fighting culture or
whatever those guys do not like they the
GOS is like you want to make humans look
like Swiss cheese and like that's how
they aren't able to survive and there's
so precision where if the hostage is
like I'm gonna don't come closer I'm
gonna shoot and pretend it's like
eyeball eyeball balls at like this just
until they won't make any mistakes
that's all crazy and this guy was a Navy
SEALs Special Forces Green Beret Green
Beret oh that's the army right yeah
frightening [ __ ] hey that's some scary
ass [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm trying to
picture this situation where it's like
you and Casey because you guys are peas
from Texas what would have happened why
can't they wrong were they cornered to
where the cars were just there there
were just both sides I don't know the
layout of how I was happening but she
just grabbed all the [ __ ] seat belts
and just [ __ ] tire ass to the
backseat try to pick Manama see they
were had already gone out of the car
what'd she do it all the cars we were
about to go into oh that's my god
oh they were hungry two things I want to
have like super secret weapons and kill
them in a way that's not very common yes
those smokeless situations and I ask you
guys a question
so in those type of situations it's all
about thinking fast right like you want
to strike first strike fast let's say
that [ __ ] happens to big-ass guys come
up to me and then first thing want my
wallet then they go hey [ __ ] get in the
[ __ ] car if I go run what do you do
I'm running perfect that's good and then
that we're all in trouble
if you just start sprinting in the
opposite direction then they won't be
able to sell your [ __ ] see I feel like
if that was Mary O'Mara be like what
what what yeah probably be me though in
it like in the moment like right now I'm
like [ __ ] you're odd but then they're
like I don't even I don't even have to
tell just to run yourself Joe we do this
like I'll be like well we talk about it
we have protocol but then she does this
like naturally we'll be walking down the
street holding hands right and if there
is a like a crazy guy doing kung fu in
the middle of the street she just lets
go of my hand because she's like I gotta
I gotta get ready to run
best buddy she goes like this so you
ready to go hold on I'm using as a
hostage she has a gun to your face but
she gets in position she's like there
she goes are you gonna be my shield and
I'm like all right all right
but I could trust her though because
when some [ __ ] went down at the UH at
the airport right I was like oh [ __ ]
should I stop this guy and I look back
and she's already gone like that's my
girl you know what you're going she
actually tied your leg to the church I
gotta use you as distraction what do
they say it's like I don't got to run
that fast I just gotta be faster than
you yeah I probably wait for you
Muriel's to innocent she's such a sweet
girl dude she would just freak the [ __ ]
out me I'm screaming I feel like I would
freeze like I'd be like frozen in like
what a lot of people freeze Oh Oh 100%
I'd freeze - there's a lot of possibles
going on I would have been like what the
[ __ ] because you also don't think if
someone's robbing you they want your
wife oh yeah you think they'd want to
take a human being you go okay just take
my money you you sack of [ __ ] all right
I immediately gave him his phone as well
I was like whatever buy an indigo I want
your wife for that you know she's
pregnant she's used like what the [ __ ]
and even if you're armed if someone is
like trying to steal from you that's
different like you don't want to kill
them cuz they're stealing from you
that's different like you know it's not
like because once they say get get your
wife and they card that's a different
story now it's time to kill yeah yeah so
they still haven't caught these guys
they're still on the run that's sucks
but they do have this drawing of the
dude that did the stabbing first of all
that's it there that's Dan Bilzerian
that's a pretty dope drawing by the way
like the the you know the cop portrait
art is like I was trying to do some he
was trying to do some like what do you
call it airbrushed t-shirt art that's
great yeah he was that's dope this was a
good artist it's [ __ ] Danville's
Aryan not sweet
definitely listen to like a Rick Ross
mixtape and he just [ __ ] that [ __ ] up
he was like [ __ ] I don't know he looks
latino he could be black he could be
white he looks like a big [ __ ]
it up yeah yeah so they're saying like
oh he's about 6 1 in his 30s so if you
guys recognize this dude in Houston he
was a big guy he's intimidating yeah
knowing David he's like see you later
babe yeah yeah the cops - the cops are
saying that like seeing is like how he
was just stabbing this dude like he
wasn't close he doesn't give it look
like he could not give a [ __ ] if he
killed this dude the cops are saying
like he is highly dangerous so they're
really trying to get it work - guys what
did the other guy look like I don't know
it's just Smeagol they just released
this dude cuz he was on that actually
did like the stabbing see when you meet
like a big guy like that I just got a
run and they'll get tired that's true
you just gotta run 100% yeah but they
have a short sprint life like 40 yards
are tired
yeah buddy running yeah but they're
gonna [ __ ] catch me in the first
three Oh [ __ ] they sprint really fast
zigzag let's take this to reality most
fat guys can't yeah all right
most fat guys if you're that [ __ ] big
they're not gonna roll and I thought
footballers aren't robbing people and
they're also the NFL so let's take that
to reality like if I came up and I was
gonna rob you write and you jetted it
I'm pretty much just [ __ ] it's like give
me a god dad
and I just sit there just like that
maybe there were just too damn close cuz
they maybe they're just fighting cuz I
mean if he's close enough to stab they
didn't have distance that's what he has
to put blades on his elbows and [ __ ] and
his [ __ ] wrist and he starts going
it's your [ __ ] gauge man yeah how
dope would that be my head did you start
so it's like this yeah and it's like
this there's like multiple plays you
would just do that look
[Music]
you can't own a gun either and then
we'll just be had to see that a crime
like the who stabbed him how it was even
possible it's like I got myself arrest
me
[Music]